GRIFF: YOU ARE LOOKING AT LIVE
IMAGES FROM FOX FLIGHT TEAM OVER
EAGLE PASS, TEXAS, PART OF THE
DEL RIO SECTOR WHERE IN THE LAST
24 HOURS 1,284 APPREHENSIONS
BRINGING THE FISCAL YEAR JUST 29
DAYS IN AT ALMOST 39,000 YET
MIGRANTS CONTINUE TO STREAM INTO
THE U.S. AT AN ALARMING RATE.
LET'S BRING IN THE SPOKESPERSON
FOR THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY IN SOUTH TEXAS
REGION, LIEUTENANT CHRIS
OLIVAREZ, YOU AND I HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME COVERING THE CRISIS
AND I'M JUST STRUCK BY THE FACT
THAT AS WE ARE JUST 29 DAYS INTO
THE FISCAL YEAR IT DOESN'T SEEM
THAT THINGS ARE SLOWING DOWN BY
THE STRETCH OF THE NATION.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU ESPECIALLY
AS WE TALK ABOUT HUMAN
SMUGGLING, CONTINUING INCREASE
IN HUMAN SMUGGLING EVENTS IN THE
EAGLE PASS AREA AND WE CONTINUE
TO SEE DRIVERS FROM LARGER
METROPOLITAN AREAS, HOUSTON,
DALLAS, EVEN OUT OF STATE MAKING
DRIVE TO THE BORDER BECAUSE IT
CONTINUES TO BE PUBLICIZED AND
RECRUIT DRIVERS TO EXPAND
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE IN HUMAN
SMUGGLING.
IT'S A MULTIBILLION DOLLAR
TRADE.
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS ARE
MAKING MORE MONEY ON HUMAN
SMUGGLING THAN THEY ARE ON DRUGS
AND WE CONTINUE TO SEE DIFFERENT
TRENDS OF SMUGGLING THROUGHOUT
THE BORDER.
GRIFF: LTI, I THINK ONE OF THE
MOST INSIGHTFUL ASPECTS IN
SMUGGLING ARE AMAZING VIDEOS
THAT YOU YOURSELF AND LUPE AND
YOUR TEAM PUT OUT TO HAVE DAILY
SMUGGLING ATTEMPTS THAT ARE
FORWARDED.
THIS ONE YOU SHOT AND RELEASED
THIS WEEK IN EAGLE PASS AREA,
HOW MIGRANTS IN PICKUP STRUCK IS
STUNNING.
>> THESE IMMIGRANTS ARE BEING
SMUGGLED THROUGH THE TYPE OF
METHODS, WHETHER IT'D BE IN A
CAR OR TRAILER AND IN THIS CASE
A DUMP TRUCK.
THERE WAS WELL OVER 100
IMMIGRANTS, ONE THING YOU DON'T
SEE THE VIDEO WHEN THE TROOPER
MADE STOP THERE WERE MANY
IMMIGRANTS THAT FLED FROM THE
DUMP DRUG INTO THE BRUSH BUT WE
WERE ABLE TO RESCUE 84 OF
IMMIGRANTS FROM THE DUMP TRUCK
THAT WERE CRAMMED INSIDE AND
ARREST THE DRIVER AND NOW HE'S
FACING 84 COUNTS OF HUMAN
SMUGGLING BUT, AGAIN, GRIFF,
WHAT'S IMPORTANT AND YOU BROUGHT
UP A GOOD POINT IS SOWING WHAT'S
TAKING PLACE ASIDE FROM
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS BUT EXPOSING
CRIMINAL ELEMENTS BY SHOWING
VIDEOS AND EXPLOITING THE
IMMIGRANTS AND PUTTING THEM IN
DANGER AS WELL BUT ALSO WHEN YOU
HAVE -- WHEN YOU HAVE
INEXPERIENCED ESPECIALLY FOR THE
COMMERCIAL VEHICLE, A DRIVER IN
THIS CASE, THE DRIVER DID NOT
HAVE THE PROPER LICENSE TO
OPERATE A COMMERCIAL VEHICLE, SO
YOU'RE DRIVING AN 80,000-POUND
VEHICLE ON A ROADWAY, IT'S NOT
ONLY ENDANGERING THE LIVES OF
BUT ABLE TO ENHANCE ALONG THE
BORDER AND MAKE SURE THEY ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL AND
STATE REGULATIONS BUT ALSO TO
FOCUS ON THE CRIMINAL SMUGGLING
ORGANIZATIONS.
GRIFF: THE SMUGGLERS, THEY ARE
JUST COMPLETELY RUTHLESS
DISREGARD FOR THE SAFETY AND
WELL-BEING OF THE MIGRANTS.
YOU KNOW, LT, I WANT TO MENTION
AS NATE FOY POINTED OUT IN GREAT
REPORTING TODAY, CHIEF ORTIZ THE
BORDER PATROL TWEETED OUT 7-DAY
RESULTS APPREHENSION AND WHAT
NOT AMONG THEM THE CRIMINAL
MIGRANTS, SOME 7 SEXUAL
OFFENDERS, ONE MURDERER, 3
MIGRANTS CRIMINALS WITH GUNS AND
IT'S BEEN AN INCREASE OF THE
DANGERS NOT EVERYONE IS FROM THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN COUNTRIES
SEEKING PEACEFUL ASYLUM.
IT'S A POINT THAT IS CONSTANTLY
MADE AND I WANT TO ASK YOU, ARE
YOU AT ALL SURPRISED OR EVEN
FRUSTRATED THAT WE ARE HEARING
SO MUCH ABOUT CRIME THIS
ELECTION CYCLE IN CITIES LIKE
PHILADELPHIA, IN NEW YORK, THE
SHOOTINGS PUSHING ON SUBWAY AND
THEY DON'T MAKE THE CONNECTION
WITH THE CRIMINAL ASPECT COMING
ACROSS OUR BORDER.
IT'S LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION.
>> GREAT POINT, GRIFF.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY GOING UNTIL NOVEMBER
BECAUSE THE BORDER CRISIS
IMPACTS NOT JUST THOSE BORDER
COMMUNITIES BUT THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
WE TALK ABOUT CRIME AND NOT JUST
THOSE CRIMINAL IMMIGRANTS COMING
ACROSS OUR BORDERS WHICH YOU
HAVE SEEN MANY TIMES WHEN YOU
HAVE BEEN OUT THERE IN PRIVATE
RANCHES THE TYPE OF PEOPLE THAT
WE ENCOUNTER ON A DAILY BASIS
AND ALSO THOSE REPORTED BY U.S.
BORDER PATROL, BUT THAT IS --
THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO FOCUS ON THE CRIMINAL ELEMENT
AND THE CRIME TAKEN PLACE ALONG
THE BORDER WITH SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS COMING ACROSS, YOU
REPORTED IT AND SEVERAL WEEKS
AGO WHEN WE CAME ON INDIVIDUAL
FROM A PRIVATE RANCH IN HONDURAS
WANTED FOR MURDER AND ONE
INDIVIDUAL THAT WE CAME ACROSS.
HOW MANY MORE HAVE GOTTEN BY
ESPECIALLY TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
THE NUMBER OF GOT AWAYS, ALMOST
A MILLION KNOWN GOT AWAYS.
THAT SHOULD BE A SERIOUS ISSUE
THAT AMERICANS NEED TO FOCUS ON
BECAUSE IT'S A THREAT NOT ONLY
TO THE BORDER COMMUNITIES BUT A
THREAT TO OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
AS WELL BECAUSE AGAIN, EVEN WITH
THE 98 TERRORISTS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPREHENDED AS WELL.
ONE TERRORIST THAT IS MORE THAN
ENOUGH TO GET ACROSS OUR BORDER,
WHEN YOU SEE CLOSE TO 100,
THAT'S A SERIOUS THREAT TO O